what I want to do in this video is
compare investment to consumption and
we're going to think about it in two
contexts one I would call the everyday
conventional context and then the other
one would be how we would think about it
in an economics context because these
words mean something very something very
particular to an economist and that's
important that it means something
particular because we're going to start
using these words or this terminology
these classifications to understand
where GDP is coming from so at every day
so let me draw a line over here so this
is going to be this is kind of everyday
everyday or conversational versions of
this term and know down here we'll put
the economics the economic the economic
versions of this term especially when we
think of it in the in the context of
accounting for GDP and they're not
necessarily all that different but they
are different in important ways so an
investment really in both cases you can
generally view it is something that you
do to get some future gains so for
example if I today build a house so I
build a house so that is the house I
built today and then this will be the
timeline the house will keep lasting and
it's an investment because it's going to
be giving me future gain a year from now
I'll still be able to live in that house
so I will have the saved rent that's a
future gain future gain two years from
now it'll keep giving some type of gain
you could have a financial instrument
maybe some type of debt instrument
you're lending money to someone else so
maybe maybe you buy a bond which is
essentially you lending money to someone
else that is an investment because in
the in the everyday sense of it because
when you when you make when you have
that asset you've bought that asset it's
going to pay off something in the future
it's going to pay off some interest or
what if some profits and in the everyday
sense I would consider something like
hopefully it would be going to college
would be an investment so education I'll
state education because you invest that
time and energy in education it's going
to keep paying off hopefully by doing
that you're going to get better
employment and higher wages the rest of
your life it will keep paying off so
this is the everyday notion of
investment the everyday notion of
consumption
the way I think about it is you are you
are buying something or you're doing
something that you're just going to use
up in the short-term and just by using
it up so whatever whatever that object
is if you just use it up so use use it
up and it's just going to hopefully
benefit you in some way but it's more of
a short-term thing I would consider that
consumption in the everyday sense so if
you go buy a candy bar and eat it you
have consumed the candy bar you have not
made an investment if you go to a movie
that is consumption and I'm not making
any value judgment that one is better
than the other investment at the end of
the day you are investing so that you
can get future future benefit that could
lead to consumption because at the end
of the consumption is one of the things
that might make your life a little bit
better off so I'm not saying that one is
better than the other but watching a
movie that would also be consumption
spending time buying a book well you
could debate whether that's education or
not but let's say you're you you buy a
book that is not educational that is
consumption but it is making you happier
hopefully it's making your life better
in some way now the economic definitions
are related to these everyday
definitions but they're a little bit
more precise and they make the
definitions in a way that they're easier
to account for if you are a nation
they're easier to keep track of so the
way an economist would define it they
would defined economic investment as
spending on capital equipment capital
equipment so capital equipment are
things like are things like if you are a
factory you will buy the equipment to
run your factory you buy the robots and
you buy the assembly line and you buy
the wheelbarrows or whatever else things
that have to cart things around that is
capital equipment it would be things
like inventory inventory so for example
the inventory this is still not so
different both of these things are being
used to produce things in the future to
produce future benefit you're buying
that inventory sometimes raw material
you're going to add value to it and then
they're going to be used to produce
something in the future it includes it
includes things like even the structures
the buildings the structures and and so
for all of this
economic sense and this was why it's
easier to account for this for the most
part is being done by the firm's and it
also includes
it also includes the one thing that
households do which is build
construction of new homes new new homes
this is from the households households
actually the buying of a house does not
show up in consumption or investment
because nothing new was produced
something just changed hands so whenever
we talk about any of these things
especially when we're talking about it
in kind of precise economic terms
it's the production of new capital
equipment new inventory new structures
new homes if I just buy a factory from
someone else that does not add to GDP
would not be considered investment or
consumption because I'm just
transferring an asset from one person to
another it would only be added to GDP
when it is first created and on the
consumption side from an economic point
of view so let me draw a little bit of a
line right over here
consumption is considered to be any
spending any spending on final goods on
final goods by households by households
except for new homes except for new
homes and let me make this even clearer
because we remember if we're just
transferring goods that shouldn't count
so let me put it on new on newly
produced final goods
now what's unintuitive a little bit over
here is according to the the way we
account for GDP you're the tuition that
you spend on a college education that is
new spending on final goods and here the
final goods let me write final goods or
services the service you're getting is
your education that would be consumption
in it so education would fall here in
the economic sense while in the everyday
sense I would consider education right
over here maybe you are buying a car and
you're not buying a car for leisure
purposes you're buying a car because you
need your car to go to work that could
is there's an argument that that would
be an investment in the everyday sense
by buying by having that car you have
something that can take you to work
every day so you're getting future
benefits so there's an argument that
maybe that's an investment in the
everyday sense but in the
since that car so the car would sit
right here you bought a new car but that
is considered consumption you did not
you did not buy a new house and the
whole reason that at least as far as I
understand the whole reason why it's set
up this way is this is easier to account
for you look at all of the spending by
firms that's easy to account for you
essentially call that investment because
at the end of the day all the spending
that firms are making is they're doing
it to produce some good or service so we
call this investment any spending that
the firms do and then on top of that
when households purchase new homes we
also call that investment and that's
just easier for for the accounting
Offices of governments to keep track of
and everything else that households do
we consider consumption and we'll see in
the next few videos are a few other
categories in terms of things that the
government do and then we'll have to
think about imports and exports